und zwar handelt es sich dabei um den
gegenstand über den ich mich so sehr so
lange gefreut habe weil ich mir dann
einfach das war so das erste casting was
ich mir von meinen youtube einnahmen
finanziert haben eigentlich was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
bio er ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt
bevor ihr jetzt den titel vom video
gelesen habt und euch denkt will jetzt
hier irgendwie mit sachen reflexen die
der sich gekauft hat für 20.000 euro von
seinen vielen youtube money von dem
manche glaube ich denken dass das
wesentlich mehr ist als es letztendlich
dann wirklich ist vor allem in
deutschland geht ja so viel geld an
steuern flöten da bin ich manchmal
wirklich traurig drüber aber was willst
du machen so ist das halt
zunächst muss ich sagen mir wurde
letztens im video vorgeschlagen und zwar
das von dem youtube-kanal dieser blende
ich euch immer ein das ist nämlich der
vater von oskar das ja auch so eine
youtube der macht so bleibt also falls
sie das sehen ich fand es wirklich sehr
interessant und zwar hat er im video mal
aus seiner sicht als erwachsener vater
ich bin jetzt mal so 50 jahre alt
schätzt 95 tollsten dinge gezeigt die er
sich in seinem leben schon gekauft
hatten wenn man so den titel hört denkt
man ja immer so ok dass wir bestimmt ein
bisschen trotzig war es aber in diesem
video gar nicht also ich fand da kam so
voll diese bescheidenheit über weswegen
ich die videos auch gar nicht mal
schlecht finde ich habe dann überlegt
vielleicht machst du auch mal so ein
video dazu und gibt seinen zuschauern
sollen einblick in die fünf teuersten
dinge die du dir in deinem leben bis
jetzt finanziert hat bei mir ja nur
wegen youtube das ist meine
haupteinnahmequelle ich hab es dann auch
hier und da noch ein bisschen was
anderes aber ich habe mir youtube auf
jeden fall bis jetzt mein meistens geld
verdient dann kam erstmal so der gedanke
okay das könnte vielleicht bei mir ein
bisschen komisch rüber kommen einfach
weil ich noch jünger bin und wenn ich
dann so sachen zeige die ich mir gekauft
habt vielleicht nehmen dass einige
falsch auch dann habe ich allerdings mal
diese fünf sachen aufgezählt ich habe
wirklich lange überlegt und mir ist
aufgefallen
bis auf eine sache sind das alles sachen
die ich mir nur gekauft habt um mein
youtube-kanal aufrecht zu halten und
bestmöglich für euch videos zu
produzieren sonst hätte ich die wirklich
gar nicht gebraucht und deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht okay das ist vielleicht
echt interessant auch mal den jüngeren
von euch so einen einblick darin zu
geben natürlich mich überrascht es immer
wieder wenn ein zwölfjähriger weiß wie
teuer
tourist oder einem pc ja das wusste ich
damals so nicht so wirklich aber ich
zeige euch heute einfach mal diese dinge
und erzählt euch ein bisschen was dazu
und ich denke das könnte interessant
werden vor allem für euch weil man sich
natürlich immer youtuber die haben ja
alle so viel geld war was aber meiner
meinung nach eigentlich gar nicht stimmt
also ich werde manchmal von leuten
gefragt die denken ich habe so und so
viel geld und da denke ich mir alter
wenn du wirst es wie viel das wirklich
ist aber ich denke mal das ist jetzt
auch nichts für die nächsten zehn jahre
man muss ja schon weiterentwickeln nicht
erzählt schon wieder viel zu lange herum
hier wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an mit
den fünf teuersten produkt na super
jetzt wollte ich euch das zeigen und mir
ist aufgefallen ich hab's nicht hier in
köln ich habe von meinen eltern und ihr
werdet jetzt sicherlich auch extrem
überrascht sein was das ist ein sonnen
kassa gegenstand ist es gar nicht wenn
euch jemand foto ein ja ich hab dir
bestimmt nehmen wir mal an und zwar sind
dass diese grauen jesus die habe ich mir
vor ungefähr einem jahr gekauft und ich
rede jetzt immer von dem betrag den ich
dafür bezahlt habe okay ich weiß auch
absolut dass sie heute nicht mehr so
viel wert sind aber wo die
herausgekommen sind wurden die zwischen
400 und 500 euro gehandelt und ich habe
die für 450 euro gekauft weil ich die
halt so toll fand und mir gedacht habe
diese schulen musst du haben würde ich
heute nie wieder machen ich werde mir
nie wieder in meinem leben schuhe kaufen
für über 150 euro glaube ich ja also
dass schon der fünfte gegenstand tut mir
leid dass ich das hier jetzt nicht
zeigen konnte
dann habe ich wirklich mal sehr lange
zurück gedacht um halt so eine
chronologische reihenfolge reinzukriegen
und ich habe so lange überlegt weil ich
der meinung war irgendwas los da doch
noch sein was du dir irgendwann mal
gekauft hast was jetzt teuer war aber da
gab es jetzt wirklich nichts krasses ich
zeige euch mal den vier teuersten
gegenstand und zwar handelt es sich
dabei um den gegenstand über den ich
mich so sehr so lange gefreut hab' weil
ich mir dann einfach das war so das
erste gasthörer ding was ich mir von
meinen youtube einnahmen finanziert habe
und was ich wirklich so lange haben
wollte weil ich damals schon ein
richtiger apple fried war
ich konnte mir zwar an ihnen iphone
leisten aber ich habe es immer so cool
gefunden und mit einem jahr 2016 von
meinen eigenen einnahmen ein macbook
kaufen zu können das war für mich
das größte und das dingen habe ich auch
immer noch ein benutztes noch wir haben
hier ein macbook pro retina 13 zoll
anfang 2015 wo das ding produziert ich
muss sagen dass immer noch ein top gerät
das benutze ich zwar nicht so oft nur
wenn ich unterwegs sind schneide ich
damit noch mal ein video die
leistungsfähigkeit davon lässt natürlich
auch immer weiter nach trotzdem ist es
ein top gerät das ich nie vergessen
werde und dafür habe im jahr 2016 ich
weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau zwischen
1700 und 1100 euro bezahlt was natürlich
für den laptop super für geld ist aber
ich wollte es unbedingt haben und es hat
mir auch echt weitergeholfen in
videoproduktionen fotobearbeitung
photoshop und so weiter also das war auf
jeden fall richtig richtig gute
investition und ich habe es also vom
ersten youtube man ii finanziert also da
habe ich 300 tausend abonnenten hab so
im monat 2000 euro brutto verdient
ungefähr genau so war das also ihr
versteht schon in diesem video gibt es
ziemlich viel transparenz für diese
dinger und ich hoffe das kommt gut an
sagen wir's und dann machen wir weiter
mit dem nächsten produkt und das ist
vieles hier willst leiden mal kurz rüber
hey wir sind wir auch schon ihr fragt
euch jetzt sicherlich wo ist hier das
produkt ja das halte ich in der hand und
das ist genau dieses ding womit ich euch
gerade das bild versuchen zu liefern
auch wenn ich diese kamera eigentlich
fast nie dafür benutze habe ich sie
damals dafür gekauft das ist die sony
alpha 6500 geile kamera hängen auch jede
menge erinnerungen drei man so was ich
damit schon gefilmt habe eigentlich mega
viele urlaubsvideo diesmal kurz hier
kann man hier ist könnt ihr mich doppelt
sehen so sieht das schöne stück aus ich
habe die mir im sommer 2017 gekauft
einfach weil ich da voll in diesem werk
modus war und ich wollte halt aktiv für
euch los produzieren mit richtig guter
qualität und da haben ja einige freunde
von mir die sich damit sehr gut
auskennen dieses modell empfohlen was
relativ neu auf dem markt war ein super
schnellen autofokus das objektiv habe
ich mir direkt dazu kaufte das wurde mir
empfohlen weil da machen kann man so
versuchen und auch echt mit flotten der
einzige nachteil man kann den bildschirm
ich umklappen auf die kamera wenn ich
bis heute wirklich sehr sehr stolz ja
ich habe sie auch von meinem youtuber
geld finanziert sie hat knapp 2400 euro
gekostet also mit coty und objektiv was
vor der kamera für mich extrem viel geld
war also hätte mir jemand mal gesagt du
wirst du meine kamera für 2100 euro
okay die super für meine reisevideos
wenn ich irgendwo hin reise allerdings
zum blocken echt sehr sehr umständlich
würde ich mal sagen hat aber super viele
funktionen wenn man sich damit auskennt
kann ich nur empfehlen da kann man echt
gut mitarbeiten den einzigen nachteil
die nicht dann hatte die qualität ist so
gut dass ich auf meinem macbook nicht
mehr vernünftig schneiden konnte also es
hat sehr geruckelt weil das bild dass
geliefert wird halt so gut ist und dann
kommt der arbeitsspeicher nicht mehr
richtig hinterher deswegen ich dann auch
vor gut einem jahr
aufgerüstet habe und da sind wir dann
auch schon beim nächsten gegenstand ich
setzte eigentlich gerade sogar vor
ich zeige es euch mal aus dieser
perspektive und zwar ist das hier mein
geliebtes imac ist wirklich ein extrem
heißes gerät was brutale leistung hat
ich schneide da wirklich so gerne videos
dran die auch eine hohe qualität haben
meistens dann mit so einer cam hier
gefilmt wie gesagt habe ich mir vor
ungefähr einem jahr gekauft imac bettina
5 k serienmäßig ist sondern acht
gigabyte arbeitsspeicher drin ich habe
den im apple store direkt auf 16 gb
aufrüsten lassen einfach weil ich das
meiner meinung nach brauche für manche
videos oder wenn man halt mal keine
fotos bearbeiten möchte und jetzt ganz
wichtig der imac sagt mandela das imac
der mac das mit der das imax hat
eigentlich über 3000 euro kostet also
knapp 3100 meine ich sogar ich bin aber
student deswegen habe ich zehn prozent
bekommen und bin dann am ende bei 2.740
oder zwischenlanden ich meine es war die
genaue summe und das war auch eine
investition die sich extrem gelohnt hat
ja man muss einfach manchmal geld in die
hand nehmen um schneller und besser zu
arbeiten das ist ja ganz normal also ich
habe es jetzt eigentlich noch nie eine
fehlinvestition gemacht wo ich wirklich
eine menge geld in die hand genommen
auch wenn man sagen muss das erste
modell was sie geholt haben ist kaputt
gegangen dann habe ich dann halt
umgetauscht und ja deswegen funktioniert
der zeitnahme jetzt fragt ihr euch
sicherlich alex ist ein gerät nummer
eins dafür müssen wir mal kurz in die
garage wir sehen uns gleich ich bin
jetzt gerade schon was einmal schafstall
bitte ich bin jetzt gerade schon hier an
meiner uni weil ich im genau moment 20
minuten klausur schreibe und ich wollte
das video eigentlich vorher noch fertig
aufgenommen haben und deswegen machen
wir das jetzt einfach hier
ich schreibe einem 14 und 30 eine
klausur heute total spät irgendwie fragt
mich noch mehr gab das ist auf jeden
fall mein sag ich mal wertvollstes
produkt mit fett vogel scheiße drauf
also ich bin ja selbstständig
das praktisch meinen firmenwagen dazu
muss ich jetzt ein paar wichtige sachen
sagen also wir haben ihn dann ford
mustang ist der eco boost bau jahr 2017
also ist nicht das neueste modell und
ich krieg wirklich sehr oft dazu fragen
gestellt hat er warum stellt er das
schild auto nicht schafft so ich kriege
sie auch dazu fragen gestellt alex wie
teuer ist so was was zahlst du dafür wie
sieht es da aus mit unterhaltungskosten
und dafür bietet sich jetzt natürlich
mal kurz dieses video an
also ich kann erst mal so viel dazu
sagen das auto hat einen neuwert von
oder hatte einen neuwert von 45.000 euro
ich habe dann aber nicht gekauft sondern
geleast kann ich im wunderbar in meiner
situation steuerlich absetzen also es
ist eigentlich nicht mein auto ich habe
ihn trotzdem jetzt hier mit reingenommen
weil ich ihn ja an sich gerade für sitze
und ich zahlte halte einen monatlichen
beitrag führt er liegt knapp 500 euro
wie gesagt kann ich super als
firmenwagen nutzen und steuerlich
absetzen deswegen dass es viel schlauer
sein auto zu fahren als immer ic hin und
herzufahren überall wo man hin muss
meiner meinung nach und ich habe dann
halt jetzt noch ein jahr dann hätte er
noch einen wert von etwas über 20.000
euro und dann kann ich sagen kaufe ich
denn jetzt oder gebe ich ihn einfach
wieder ab deswegen das ist eigentlich
eine super sache ja so sieht das von
enders und ich muss jetzt erstmal
schnell klausur schreiben sonst komme
ich zu spät
ich bin schon wieder zurück habe das
video so weit fertig geschnitten haben
davor die klausur geschrieben an die die
es interessiert wie es gelaufen das war
ganz in ordnung also ich denke mal dass
ich das locker bestanden hat ist auf
jeden fall irgendwie ziemlich schnell
fertig vom video habe ich leider noch
kein ende gemacht deswegen mache ich das
jetzt gerne mal ins programm ab heisst
alex wie ich hoffe dass wieder durch
gefallen und hat euch ein bisschen so
seite man transparenz gegeben wenn die
dinge die man als youtuber braucht und
sich kauft und was das halt kostet wie
gesagt das soll überhaupt nicht protzig
oder sonstwas rüberkommen ich meine ich
habe ja auch eigentlich nichts protziges
das sind alles sachen die ich brauche
für meine arbeit ich hoffe das sind doch
wie man falsch auf und ja das war mir
wir sehen uns übermorgen haut rein